[Music]
a las vegas judge is firing back at a
state commission which he wants to
remove her from the bench among the
allegations raised by the judicial
discipline commission is the judge's
choice of shoes
well the justice of the peace melanie
tobiason has been re-elected multiple
times but
is now in the crosshairs of the state
commission which has accused her
of inappropriate behavior some of the
changes being some of the charges being
investigated stem from an on-camera
interview that tobiason gave to the
eight news now i-team she criticized
local law enforcement for ignoring
information that she provided
about a group of alleged pimps who were
trying to recruit teenage girls to work
for them
including the judge's own daughter an
initial investigation found the judge
did nothing wrong but the commission
then hired
a second investigator who interviewed
dozens of witnesses including some who
had complained that the judge was known
to wear
so-called quoting hooker heels as well
as inappropriate t-shirts
under her robes absolutely because they
didn't like a shirt she wore
under her robe because somebody
described
her shoes her heels as hooker heels
now imagine those kind of accusations
against a male judge it's just
preposterous it would never happen
nobody would have even the people making
the allegations would have been the one
in trouble
and instead they're going after the
judge for this and again
i can't imagine any circumstances where
they pursue a male judge based on his
clothing
you know as well as i do over the
history there's been judges wearing
shorts and flip-flops under the robes
and t-shirts and and there's never been
an issue
attorney mark cook just filed a
complaint in federal court accusing the
judicial discipline commission of
violating tobiason's constitutional
rights
cook says the commission has a recent
history of being tough on female judges
but taking feeble action against male
judges
the commission has multiple allegations
pending against judge tobias
including the ones involving her choice
of footwear
the full complaint filed in federal
court can be read on our website
dot
8newsnow.com